that was just venting about a situation
but her comments just make me want to
slap her now
Kourtney and khloé go head to head in
Bali how am I gonna get through this day
on Sunday night's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kim Khloe and Kourtney took
their kids to Indonesia for a getaway
and Scott Disick tagged along I'm
critical look at the mirror I miss this
it was Khloe's first big trip with her
daughter true intentions or high as
Chloe attempted to confide in her sister
several times I just actually don't care
so I just want to go Vaughn Scott kept
things positive and as Kim said deserved
an award for father of the year for
taking care of the kiddos while the
sisters duped it out in the end court
and Koko made up with Chloe
being the first to apologize and
Kourtney following suit
everyone has their moments we can see to
all try to do our best to like not
engage and not like top six
sico yeah I'm gonna figure it all out I
promise you we're all all gonna learn
scott admitted he was just happy to be
there on his first vacation with the
family since him in court officially
split these are these AK memories I
didn't want to miss out on I don't know
what's gonna top that
[Music]